but along the way photography became
more than a hobby it blossomed into an
obsession and in 2008 it became my third
career and the purpose of my life this
obsession was fueled by the ideas of
photographers like Eugene Smith Albert
Watson and Sam Abel especially Sam his
approach to photography would eventually
be the cornerstone of my philosophy to
making images I'll share a few of those
principles tonight where the hope they
do more than help you decode my
photographs that you might also find
them useful in your own work first and
foremost to seek soulful moments not
recreate postcards I call this
photograph of the crush it was taken in
Cusco Peru to compose and wait for that
decisive moment so I have to say after
about three hours on this lead in
Antarctica I was really starting to
question this principle but it worked
out and to make photographs that ask
questions rather than answer them
recognizing the gear doesn't matter it
took me a while to figure this one out
but I'm there today but details do a lot
this is obviously Havana to know when
just to be an observer and when to
engage
to seek love
wimzie this is Kenya and Wonder but most
importantly to always say yes to
adventure
[Music]